Bonjour à tous.
Aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un des phénomènes
les plus intrigants de la mécanique quantique,
ce qu'on appelle l'intrication.
J'avais déjà fait une vidéo d'introduction
à la mécanique quantique
et pour ceux que ne se souviendraient plus très bien
ce qu'il y avait dedans, rassurez-vous je vais faire des rappels.
Pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne connaîtraient
vraiment rien à la mécanique quantique,
je vous conseille quand même d'aller y faire un petit tour d'abord
Non?
Allez, dernière chance!
♪ [Générique] ♪
Je vous l'ai dit, on va commencer par un petit rappel
sur la manière dont fonctionne la mécanique quantique.
L'idée centrale est qu'en mécanique quantique,
les objets comme les particules
n'ont plus des propriétés bien définies.
Par exemple, les particules n'ont plus forcement
une position ou une vitesse bien déterminée,
mais elles peuvent être dans
une superposition de plusieurs états.
Un électron, par exemple, peut être dans un état
où sa vitesse est 1000km/s,
dans un état où sa vitesse est 2000km/s, ça c'est normal,
mais il peut aussi être dans
une superposition de ces deux états.
On le note comme cela, en additionnant
les états entre des crochets.
Cette idée que les propriétés des objets ne soient
plus définies est déjà perturbante en soi
mais là où la mécanique quantique devient vraiment bizarre,
c'est quand on commence à vouloir
mesurer quand même ces propriétés.
Si on considère un électron qui est
dans la superposition de ces deux états
et qu'on essaye de mesurer sa vitesse.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va trouver comme résultat?
Et bien, nous avons 50% de chance de trouver 1000km/s
et 50% de chance de mesurer 2000km/s.
Et si on mesure un grand nombre d'électrons
qui sont tous au départ dans le même état,
on aura, à peu près, 50-50 de chaque résultat.
Mais si vous isolez un électron en particulier,
vous n'avez aucun moyen de savoir à l'avance
quel résultat vous allez obtenir.
Cela ne se décide qu'au moment de la mesure
et c'est le fruit du hasard.
En mécanique quantique le hasard
intervient dans les mesures,
il y a ce qu'on appelle un indéterminisme de la mesure.
Quand on regarde ça à première vue,
il y a quand même de quoi être sceptique.
On nous dit que les particules sont
dans des états superposés.
Premier truc bizarre!
Et on nous dit que quand on essaye
de mesurer les propriétés de ces objets,
il y a une sorte de hasard cosmique qui choisit le résultat.
Deuxième truc bizarre!
Est-ce que ce n'est pas tout simplement que,
dès le départ, il n'y a pas du tout d'états superposés,
il y a juste un mélange de deux types d'électrons?
La moitié des électrons qui vont déjà à 1000km/s
et donc quand on les mesure on trouve 1000km/s
et puis l'autre moitié des électrons qui vont déjà à 2000km/s
et seront donc toujours mesurés à 2000km/s.
Et bien NON! La mécanique quantique affirme
que cette vision n'est pas correcte.
Elle nous dit que l'on peut très bien avoir,
au départ, tout un tas d'électrons
qui sont tous exactement dans le même état,
un état superposé
et que c'est la mesure qui va les forcer,
en quelque sorte, à choisir leur vitesse
et que le résultat de cette mesure
est vraiment la conséquence d'un hasard fondamental
qu'on ne peut pas prédire.
Vous-y croyez vous?
Non?
Et bien pour aller dans votre sens,
sachez qu'Einstein, qui n'était pas la moitié
d'un imbécile, n'y croyait pas non plus.
Einstein n'aimait pas du tout cette idée de hasard
fondamental qui déciderait du résultat des mesures.
Sa citation est fameuse, pour lui : "Dieu ne joue pas aux dés !"
Et notamment à la célèbre Conférence Solvay de 1927,
on en voit une photo ici,
il a eu plein de débats avec le danois Niels Bohr
qui lui, défendait l'idée d'un hasard fondamental.
C'est une vision que l'on appelle depuis,
l'interprétation de Copenhague.
Et bien figurez vous que, quelques années plus tard,
Einstein a enfin trouvé l'argument qui tue,
celui qui allait clouer le bec de Bohr ... enfin c'est ce qu'il croyait...
Mais pour vous expliquer tout ça,
il faut d'abord que je vous parle du spin!
♪ [Générique] ♪
Le spin, je dois vous avouer que j'ai hésité
à en parler dans ma première vidéo,
c'est un concept central en mécanique quantique
mais qui est quand même un peu abstrait.
Mais bon, là je crois qu'il va falloir y aller.
D'habitude quand on ne fait pas de mécanique quantique,
quand on pense à une particule, comme un électron,
c'est assez pratique de se la représenter
comme une petite boule,
genre une minuscule balle de tennis qui aurait
une certaine position, une certaine vitesse.
Sauf que quand on pense
à une balle de tennis en mouvement,
elle n'a pas seulement une position et une vitesse
mais elle peut aussi tourner sur elle même.
C'est d'ailleurs bien pratique ce mouvement
de rotation sur elle même
parce que c'est ce qui permet au tennisman
de mettre des effets comme par exemple le lift.
...
Si une balle de tennis peut tourner sur elle-même,
est-ce qu'un électron ne pourrait pas faire pareil?
Oui, le problème c'est que, pour autant qu'on sache,
un électron ce n'est pas comme une petite balle,
un electron c'est fait de rien,
ça n'a pas de taille, alors on ne voit pas très bien
comment il pourrait tourner sur lui même
et surtout comment on pourrait s'en rendre compte.
Oui, sauf que l'électron, il a une charge!
Il est chargé négativement.
Imaginons une balle de tennis qui serait chargée aussi
et qu'il y aurait des petites charges à sa surface.
Et bien si elle tournait sur elle-même, elle se mettrait
à se comporter comme un aimant.
Ça peut vous paraître étrange comme idée
mais pour vous en convaincre,
vous pouvez vous rendre compte que des charges
électriques qui tournent en cercle, comme cela,
c'est exactement le principe de l'électroaimant
que l'on peut faire en faisant
des spirales avec un fil électrique.
Donc, une balle de tennis en rotation, si elle était chargée,
elle se comporterait comme un aimant
donc nos électrons qui sont chargés négativement,
s'ils étaient en rotation sur eux-même,
ils devraient aussi réagir comme des petits aimants!
Et bien figurez-vous que c'est ce que l'on constate
dans certaines expériences.
Notamment quand on balance certains atomes
dans un champ magnétique,
du fait que les électrons se comportent
comme des petits aimants,
les atomes peuvent être déviés par le champ.
Et on a plein d'autres expériences qui vont dans le même sens
et qui semblent montrer que, effectivement, les électrons
réagissent comme des petits aimants,
tout se passe comme s'ils étaient en rotation sur eux-même.
Et pour désigner ça, on dit que les électrons possèdent un spin,
de l'anglais "spin" pour "tourner".
♪ [Acclamations de spectateurs] ♪
Ce qu'il est important de comprendre, c'est que
les électrons ne sont pas en rotation sur eux-même.
On a dit : ils ne sont fait de rien, ils n'ont pas de taille
donc on ne voit pas très bien comment
ils pourraient être en rotation physique.
Et pourtant ils ont quand même cette propriété de spin
qu'on appelle une propriété intrinsèque.
C'est un petit peu difficile de se représenter
ce qu'est une propriété intrinsèque,
mais par exemple vous pouvez penser à la masse.
C'est vrai, quand on trouve que l'électron a une certaine masse
on pourrait être tenté d’imaginer que l'électron
possède un certain volume physique,
qu'il est fait d'une matière qui a une certaine densité
et que sa masse c'est son volume fois sa densité.
Mais non, en fait il n'a pas de volume et sa masse,
c'est une propriété intrinsèque
qui ne nécessite pas que l'électron
ait une taille physique pour exister.
Et bien le spin c'est pareil!
Tout se passe comme si l'électron avait
une taille physique et tournait sur lui-même
mais en fait il ne tourne pas sur lui-même ...
mais on appelle ça quand même le spin.
Mais il y a encore plus bizarre!
Je vous ai dit que le Spin était à l'origine de la déviation
de certains atomes dans un champ magnétique
et intuitivement on s’attendrait à ce que l'ampleur de la déviation
soit liée à l'intensité et l'orientation du spin.
On s’attendrait donc à voir des atomes qui seraient
plus ou moins déviés dans un sens ou dans un autre
voire, pas déviés du tout pour certains.
Sauf que ce n'est pas ce qu'on observe.
Pour un réglage donné de l'expérience, ce que l'on
observe c'est que les atomes sont toujours déviés,
soit d'une certaine quantité vers le haut,
soit de la même quantité vers le bas
mais pas plus et jamais entre les deux!
C'est comme si pour un électron le spin n'avait
que deux valeurs possibles, c'est tout.
Et du coup ces deux valeurs on les note généralement + et -
ou alors une petite flèche vers le haut
et une petite flèche vers le bas.
Ça ne vous rappelle rien ça?
Le spin, c'est ce que l'on appelle une propriété quantifiée,
c'est-à-dire que comme les niveaux d'énergie
de l'atome d'hydrogène,
elle ne peut prendre qu'un certain nombre de valeurs possibles
et en l’occurrence ici, seulement deux valeurs.
C'est assez bizarre mais vous allez voir
que c'est aussi assez pratique
♪ [Générique] ♪
Pourquoi est-ce que le spin est aussi
important en mécanique quantique?
Et bien parce que c'est la propriété quantique
la plus simple que l'on connaisse
puisqu'elle ne peut prendre que deux valeurs.
En haut, en bas et puis, bien sûr,
toutes les superpositions de ces deux états.
Et oui, on fait quand même de la mécanique quantique là!
Et avoir seulement deux états superposés
c'est quand même très pratique pour faire des calculs.
On est loin de ces électrons qui peuvent
être n'importe où dans l'espace
et qu'il faut décrire avec une onde de probabilité etc...
Là, non non, seulement deux états.
Et pour faire des expériences, c'est aussi beaucoup plus simple!
Et donc si on réinterprète l'expérience
de déviation dans un champ magnétique
avec le langage de la mécanique quantique,
en gros, on a qu'il est possible d'avoir des électrons
qui soient dans une superposition d'états + et -, au départ
et que si on les balance dans un champ magnétique,
50% des électrons choisis au hasard vont être déviés vers le haut
et se retrouveront projetés dans l'état +
et 50% vont aller vers le bas et seront projetés dans l'état - .
Ça c'est l’interprétation usuelle de la mécanique quantique.
Mais si on revient à notre troupe de départ, qu'est-ce
qui nous prouve que c'est vraiment ça qu'il se passe?
Et pas plutôt que, dès le départ, on avait
50% des électrons qui étaient dans l'état +
et 50% des électrons qui étaient dans l'état -
et qu'il n'y ait pas du tout de superposition, de projection, etc...?
Et ça, d'une certaine manière, c'était ce que pensait Einstein!
Alors, je vous ai dit tout à l'heure dans son débat avec Bohr
il avait fini par trouver un argument qui tue
pour réfuter l'interprétation traditionnelle
de la mécanique quantique.
Mais pour comprendre son argument,
il faut que l'on passe à deux électrons.
Si on a deux électrons on a donc deux spins
et si, pour commencer, on ignore le fait
qu'on puisse faire des superpositions,
on a 4 situations possibles.
Les 2 électrons sont dans l'état + .
Ou alors le premier est + et le second est - .
Ou bien le premier est - et le second est + .
Et enfin les deux sont - .
Si maintenant on admet qu'en mécanique quantique
on peut avoir superposition de plusieurs états
et bien on peut être dans un mélange de ces 4 situations.
Il y a une chose que vous vous souvenez
peut-être de ma première vidéo,
c'est que quand on fait des superpositions d'état,
on peut faire varier les proportions,
un peu comme dans un cocktail.
Et parmi toutes les superpositions
possibles quand il y a deux spins,
il y en a une qui est particulièrement intrigante.
C'est celle où l'on superpose uniquement les deux états + - et - + .
Cette superposition est ce que l'on appelle un état intriqué
et la raison de cette appellation est que
quand deux particules sont dans cet état,
elles se retrouvent irrémédiablement liées l'une à l'autre,
on va voir pourquoi.
Imaginez que l'on mesure le spin du premier électron.
On a une chance sur deux de le trouver dans l'état +
et une chance sur deux de le trouver dans l'état - .
Sauf que supposons que nous le trouvons
effectivement dans l'état - .
Vous voyez que ça signifie que le second électron,
lui, il est obligatoirement dans l'état +
et réciproquement.
C'est-à-dire qu'une fois qu'on a mesuré le spin d'un des électrons,
celui de l'autre se trouve obligatoirement déterminé,
les deux mesures doivent forcément correspondre.
C'est pour ça qu'on dit que les deux particules
sont dans un état intriqué.
Et c'est en utilisant cette situation qu’Einstein
a proposé une expérience de pensée
qui, pour lui, allait démolir l'interprétation
traditionnelle de la mécanique quantique.
♪ [Générique] ♪
En 1935, avec deux autres physiciens, Podolsky et Rosen,
Einstein a publié un article scientifique
qui présentait un paradoxe
qui depuis porte leurs initiales, on l'appelle le paradoxe EPR.
L'idée est la suivante :
Imaginez qu'on ait 2 électrons dans un état intriqué :
(+/-) et (-/+) supperposés
et qu'on éloigne les 2 électrons l'un de l'autre.
Imaginons qu'on mesure le spin du premier
et qu'après on mesure le spin du second.
Si on en croit l'interprétation usuelle
de la mécanique quantique,
tant que la première mesure n'a pas été faite
le résultat est indéterminé
on a toujours un état superposé
et c'est la première mesure qui, en quelque sorte,
choisi le résultat au hasard entre + et -.
Sauf que pour que le résultat de la deuxième mesure
soit en accord avec celui de la première,
on a envie de penser qu'il faut que quelque chose
se transmette pour communiquer le résultat.
Pourquoi pas. Sauf que ce que remarque
Einstein, Podolski et Rosen,
c'est que si on éloigne suffisamment les électrons
et qu'on fait les mesures suffisamment proches,
presque simultanément,
cette transmission devrait aller
plus vite que la vitesse de la lumière.
♪ [Bande son de Star Wars] ♪
Hors Einstein était bien placé pour savoir que rien
ne peut aller plus vite que la vitesse de la lumière,
puisque c'est lui qui avait formalisé cette idée
dans sa théorie de la relativité restreinte
et donc de ce paradoxe EPR Einstein conclu
qu'il y a forcément un problème
avec la mécanique quantique
telle qu'on l'avait proposée à l'époque
et notamment avec ces idées d'états superposés
et de hasard qui choisirait le résultat de la mesure.
Pour lui une manière plus raisonnable
d'envisager les choses
c'est d'imaginer que la description
avec superposition d'état est incomplète
et qu'il y a forcément de l'information
supplémentaire quelque part.
Par exemple, on pourrait imaginer que
quand les électrons se séparent,
ils se mettent d'accord secrètement
sur quel état ils vont tomber s'il y a une mesure
et ça permettrait d'éliminer à la fois l'idée de hasard
et en plus le besoin d'avoir une transmission
plus rapide que la vitesse de la lumière.
Cette vision c'est celle qu'on appelle parfois
celle des "variables cachées"
parce qu'elle considère qu'il y a des variables
supplémentaires qui sont cachées,
mais qui conditionne le résultat des mesures.
C'est un petit peu comme quand
on lance une pièce à pile ou face,
on a l'impression que c'est le hasard qui choisit
mais en fait il y a des variables qui sont cachées
comme la position de la pièce,
sa vitesse de rotation, etc..., et qui déterminent
à l'avance le résultat de la mesure
si on connaissait ces variables on serait capables
de prédire de quel côté la pièce va tomber.
Donc grâce à ce paradoxe EPR, Einstein pensait
qu'il avait gagné le débat avec Bohr.
Puisque rien ne peut aller plus vite que la lumière,
cette expérience de pensée
montre qu'il y a forcément des variables cachées
en mécanique quantique
et donc que la mécanique quantique est incomplète.
♪ [Générique] ♪
A l'époque, en 1935, Einstein avait proposé ça
comme une expérience de pensée,
il faisait toujours des expériences de pensée
mais il ne faisait jamais les vraies expériences.
Ce qu'il faut dire, c'est que depuis,
on a réussi à faire cette expérience.
En pratique on n'utilise généralement pas des électrons,
mais plutôt des photons
et ce n'est pas leur spin qu'on mesure,
c'est leur polarisation,
mais pour nous ça revient à peu près au même.
Et bien figurez vous que l'expérience se passe
exactement comme prévu par le paradoxe EPR.
Si on fabrique 2 photons dans un état intriqué,
qu'on les sépare et qu'on mesure la polarisation de l'un,
ça détermine automatiquement et immédiatement
la polarisation de l'autre, à distance
et quelle que soit la distance qui les sépare.
Le record actuel est quand même de 13km je crois,
ça veut dire que dans l'expérience, tout se passe comme
si un photon était capable d'influencer un autre photon
quasiment instantanément à 13km de distance.
Donc si on suit Einstein, c'est forcement
qu'il y a des variables cachées quelque part...
à moins qu'Einstein ait tort et que cette influence
instantanée à distance existe vraiment.
Les choses auraient pu en rester là,
sauf que dans les années 60,
un mathématicien du nom de Bell a proposé
un moyen de trancher le débat par l'expérience
et de savoir s'il y avait vraiment
des variables cachées ou pas.
Ce qu'a démontré Bell est un petit peu technique
alors je ne vais pas rentrer dans les détails,
mais ça concerne, en gros, ce qu'il se passe quand
on mesure le lien entre les polarisations des 2 particules,
en mettant un angle légèrement différent
entre les 2 détecteurs.
Ce qu'a démontré Bell, c'est que
dans une théorie à variables cachées,
la corrélation entre les 2 mesures
obéit forcement à certaines inégalités,
on appelle ça les inégalités de Bell.
Alors qu'en mécanique quantique, en tout cas
selon son interprétation traditionnelle,
d'après les calculs, on doit avoir des corrélations
plus élevées que ces inégalités.
On dit que la mécanique quantique
viole les inégalités de Bell.
Ce résultat théorique très important de Bell
a ouvert la voie à un moyen de trancher le débat
entre Einstein et les tenants
de l'interprétation de Copenhague.
Einstein était déjà mort, mais ce n'est pas grave.
Cette expérience à été réalisée
pour la première fois par une équipe française,
celle d'Alain Aspect à Orsay en 1982.
Alain Aspect, qui est un spécialiste de l'optique et des lasers,
a montré que dans son montage particulier
qui utilise la polarisation des photons,
les inégalités de Bell étaient violées.
Ce résultat peut vous paraître un petit peu abstrait,
mais ce qu'il faut retenir, c'est que cette expérience
montre que la mécanique quantique ne peut pas
être une théorie à variables cachées
et que, donc, Einstein avait tort,
et que l'interprétation de Copenhague,
celle de Bohr et compagnie, elle tient la route.
Il n'y a pas de variables cachées et c'est, à priori,
bien le hasard qui détermine le résultat des mesures.
L'expérience d'Alain Aspect est vraiment
une expérience fondatrice,
c'est une des plus importantes de la mécanique
quantique et peut-être même de toute la physique.
D'ailleurs, je ne sais pas pourquoi
il n'a toujours pas eu le prix Nobel.
Pourtant, l'expérience d'Aspect avait quelques failles.
En temps normal, on n'aurait
peut-être pas été très très regardant,
mais là, la question est tellement fondamentale
que si on se fait un peu l'avocat du diable,
on peut se dire qu'il subsiste un petit doute
et que donc, peut-être que, quand même,
il y a des variables cachées en mécanique quantique.
Donc, depuis les années 80, il y a eu plein de groupes
de recherche dans le monde qui ont essayé
de faire des expériences similaires à celle d'Alain Aspect
en essayant de corriger les failles
et elles ont montré que toutes les failles
pouvaient être corrigées
et les expériences confirment, à chaque fois,
le résultat d'Aspect et de son équipe,
les inégalités de Bell sont violées
et il ne peut pas y avoir de variables cachées.
Sauf que jusqu'ici, on avait montré qu'il était possible
de corriger toutes les failles une par une,
mais jamais toutes en même temps et donc on
n'avait pas d'expérience analogue à celle d'Alain Aspect
qui corrige toutes les failles à la fois.
En octobre 2015, une équipe de recherche
à l'université de Delft aux Pays-Bas
a publié pour la première fois
les résultats d'une expérience
dans lesquels toutes les failles ont été corrigées.
Et bien, figurez-vous que ça marche toujours,
les inégalités de Bell sont violées.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut retenir de tout ça?
Tout d'abord, que l'interprétation que l'on donne
usuellement de la mécanique quantique
avec ses états superposés, le hasard qui intervient
dans les mesures, la projection, etc...,
ça semble tenir la route.
Au début de la vidéo, on s'était demandés
si les états superposés
et le hasard quantique
dans les mesures existaient vraiment,
ou si c'était juste le résultat de notre ignorance
de l'état exact des particules, dès le départ.
Sauf qu'il y a quand même un prix à payer pour tout ça,
souvenez-vous du paradoxe EPR.
Le fait qu'il y ait des états intriqués
nous oblige à admettre la possibilité
que des mesures peuvent s'influencer
plus vite que la vitesse de la lumière.
Est-ce que ça ne viole pas la relativité restreinte ça ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Et bien non, en fait, la violation
des inégalités de Bell et le paradoxe EPR
ne sont pas en contradiction avec la relativité restreinte.
L'argument détaillé est assez technique,
mais il faut vous imaginer que, en gros, on ne peut pas
utiliser ça pour faire de la communication à distance
parce quand il y a une mesure,
le résultat est déterminé au hasard,
vous n'avez pas moyen de choisir le résultat,
vous le subissez
et donc vous ne pouvez pas utiliser
le paradoxe EPR et les états intriqués
pour vraiment communiquer à distance.
Le point qu'il faut préciser, c'est que les expériences
d'Aspect et la violation des inégalités de Bell
ne permettent d'exclure que les théories
à variables cachées dites locales.
En fait, on peut sauver le déterminisme
et l'idée des variables cachées
si on les autorise à être non locales, c'est-à-dire
à ne pas être attachées à un point de l'espace,
mais, en quelque sorte, à exister à plusieurs endroits à la fois.
Au final, ce qu'il faut retenir de ces idées d'intrication,
c'est que la mécanique quantique, aussi loin qu'on la teste,
continue de se comporter de manière toujours
plus surprenante et contraire à notre intuition
et pourtant, un siècle après son invention,
elle marche diaboliquement bien.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
Si elle vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à la partager,
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
puisque c'est la meilleure chose que vous puissiez
faire pour m'aider à faire connaitre la chaîne.
Merci à tous ceux qui me soutiennent sur Tipeee,
merci beaucoup.
Vous avez peut-être remarqué que la qualité
des vidéos s'améliore de jour en jour,
c'est grâce à vous les tipeurs, merci beaucoup.
Et enfin comme souvent, pour ceux
qui voudraient aller un petit peu plus loin,
en savoir un petit peu plus sur le paradoxe EPR,
les inégalités de Bell, etc...,
j'ai écrit un petit billet que je mettrai
en lien, quelque part par ici.
Voilà et je termine par une petite annonce,
le 7 février je serai à Lyon
pour le festival LyonScience, donc n'hésitez pas
à aller voir le lien que je mettrai quelque part.
Vous pouvez notamment soutenir l'organisation
du festival, n'hésitez pas à le faire
et puis vous pouvez venir le 7 février à LyonScience,
ça sera l'occasion de se rencontrer et puis il n'y aura
pas que moi, il y aura plein d'autres gens biens.
Il y aura Sébastien Carassou du Sense of Wonder,
Florence Porcel, Lison Bernet,
il y aura plein de gens autour de la vulgarisation
scientifique, donc le 7 février à Lyon.
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui, merci beaucoup
de m'avoir suivi et à bientôt pour des nouvelles vidéos.